- [Voiceover] This is the
Southern Appalachian Salamander.
It breathes entirely through its skin,
which makes it incredibly sensitive
to water quality and temperature.
And with average temperatures
increasing yearly,
their future has become quite murky.
(quiet chime music)
The Appalachian region is home to
more salamander species than
anywhere else in the world.
Adults top out at seven inches, and females
are slightly larger than males.
They are found across the
Carolinas, Georgia and Tennessee.
They live in wet, forested areas
as they need to stay moist
to respirate properly.
Unfortunately, these areas have been
shrinking and warming up quickly.
Climate change and habitat loss
are grave concerns for
this remarkable species.
This is the Southern
Appalachian Salamander.
(quiet chime music)